[Musica]
A cosa serve la matematica
Chi di voi si è mai posto questa domanda
su alzate le mani chi si è chiesto
almeno una volta nella vita A cosa serve
la matematica non siate timidi So che ve
lo siete chiesto almeno una volta e vi
dico anche quando è stata l'ultima volta
Pochi istanti fa Avete sentito che
eravate qui per ascoltare un professore
di matematica e avete pensato ma chi me
l'ha fatto fare divenire al Ted per
sentirmi parlare di matematica a me A
cosa serve la matematica e se anche per
caso non l'avete mai pensato sicuramente
questa frase L'avete sentita l'ha detta
qualcuno
io e tutti i docenti di matematica
questa frase La sentiamo spesso molto
troppo spesso e sicuramente L'avete
sentita anche voi Beh quando vi sblocco
un ricordo siamo in seconda media
lezione di matematica la professoressa e
alla lavagna sta spiegando il teorema di
Pitagora
la scena è quella che immaginate c'è chi
passa un bigliettino al compagno c'è chi
cerca di mangiare due biscottini chi sta
giocando a tris col vicino chi pensa ad
una ragazza che gli piace Insomma sono
in due o tre quelli che ascoltano
davvero la lezione ma a un certo punto
un ragazzo Alza la mano la professoressa
quasi si commuove c'è qualcuno che sta
ascoltando davvero la lezione e invece
no è lui il più splendido della classe
che fa quella domanda a me cosa mi serve
sapere il teorema di Pitagora
Beh oggi voglio raccontarvi a cosa vi
serve il teorema di Pitagora e a cosa vi
serve la matematica ma per farlo
Lasciatemi prendere una strada lunga
voglio raccontarvi Alcune storie quindi
liberiamo un attimo la mente non siamo
più in una scuola media ma siamo in
ospedale siamo al pronto soccorso avete
un fortissimo mal di pancia siete lì al
pronto soccorso Appunto perché questo
mal di pancia non vi lascia stare volete
assolutamente capire che cosa avete vi
visita un medico e ovviamente per
scoprire che cosa avete iniziato a
stargli a chiedervi Dove vi fa male se
avete mangiato qualcosa di particolare
fa un sacco di domande vi tocca eccetera
ma il male è dentro di voi e il medico
non può guardare dentro di voi se
potesse vedere che cosa c'è magari
capirebbe meglio che cosa avete E allora
quale sarebbe un buon modo Beh un moro
sarebbe prendere un bristore aprirvi la
pancia e vedere cosa succede un modo un
po' invasivo forse se avete davvero
tanto male potreste anche accettarlo ma
non è sicuramente la strada migliore
Qual è la strada migliore Ah se solo ci
fosse un modo per guardare dentro di voi
senza aprirvi davvero la pancia ma quel
modo lo sappiamo tutti che c'è Lo
sappiamo tutti e allora diciamolo tutti
assieme questo modo è l'anti trasformata
di radoncoli
un attimo un attimo un attimo mi state
dicendo che non la conoscete Cioè voi
non passate le stati sulla spiaggia con
gli amici a parlare di analisi
funzionale
Scusate Allora devo essermi sbagliato un
attimo chiamiamola con un altro nome
quello che vi serve è la TAC la tac è lo
strumento che serve appunto per vedere
all'interno del vostro corpo senza
affettarlo Come funziona manda
semplicemente dei raggi all'interno del
vostro corpo vede come vengono assorbiti
vengono assorbiti diversamente dalle
ossa dei tessuti molli da tessuti di
vari tipi e poi un computer Calcola e
mostra il medico l'interno del vostro
corpo ma questo strumento è
semplicemente la realizzazione pratica
di uno strumento matematico l'anti
trasformata di radon nicolin inventata
da due matematici radon e Nico questo
punto nel 1917 non avevano assolutamente
in mente questa cosa quando hanno fatto
questo risultato di analisi funzionale
di pura matematica senza nessuna
applicazione Ma poi più avanti un fisico
e un ingegnere si sono accorti che
questo strumento era esattamente lo
strumento matematico che serviva per
risolvere il vostro problema al pronto
soccorso e allora hanno usato la
matematica che conoscevano per creare la
TAC e per cambiare le cose in meglio per
voi Quando avete il mal di pancia e per
tutti noi ma a questo punto voi Mi
direte Beh ma cosa c'entra Basta che la
matematica la sappia l'ingegnere e che
la sappia usare a me cosa mi serve Beh
Permettetemi di fare una piccola
digressione questa cosa che la
matematica la debba sapere l'ingegnere a
me un come sta qui e vi racconto perché
Ero ai primi anni dell'università gli
ultimi anni dello scorso millennio i
primi di questo compensatela come volete
Quando decido di andare nella mia
vecchia scuola media a incontrare i miei
professori e le mie professoresse per
raccontargli cosa stavo facendo entro
nella mia scuola media e la prima
persona che incontro è la bidella che
era la mia bidella già una decina d'anni
prima Quando frequentavo quella scuola è
intenta come al solito a fare le pulizie
a fare delle fotocopie ma mi vede mi
dice Alberto come va Che cosa ci
racconti di bello E allora io le
racconto con Grande entusiasmo che sono
andato a studiare matematica e a quel
punto diventa triste
si legge la tristezza nei suoi occhi e
mi dice Ma come Alberto proprio tu che
eri così bravo in matematica non sei
andato a studiare ingegneria
quindi capite con l'ingegnere o qualcosa
perché se uno è bravo in matematica non
deve seguire la sua passione e studiare
matematica Perché tutti pensano che i
matematici siano inutili alla società ma
lasciamo perdere anche questo ricordo
personale di cui A voi interessa nulla e
torniamo a noi a che cosa serve a noi la
matematica Beh una risposta volente o
nolenti ce l'abbiamo avuti tutti davanti
agli occhi in questi due anni in questi
due anni se non ve ne foste accorti è
scoppiata una pandemia una pandemia con
un virus che girava un nemico invisibile
di cui non si riusciva a capire nulla e
siamo stati sommersi da grafici di
andamenti di morti di malati di terapia
Intensive di infetti e la curva come
cresce e la derivata della curva il
punto di Massimo il punto riflesso R con
zero R con t una mare termini matematici
che ci hanno invaso e di cui la maggior
parte di noi non capiva niente eravamo
totalmente persi e in una situazione del
genere devono essere prese delle
decisioni e devono essere prese delle
decisioni rapide prima che ci siano
troppi morti prima che i danni siano
troppo grandi Allora bisogna agire e i
politici devono agire tempestivamente ma
un politico non può agire se non ha il
consenso della popolazione Se non riesce
a far capire alla popolazione quanto è
importante agire in quel momento e non
agire dopo le decisioni che sono state
prese sono state decisioni dure che
hanno comportato dei danni economici
delle perdite delle difficoltà per
ognuno di noi e allora per riuscire ad
affrontare una cosa del genere la
popolazione deve avere un'idea Chiara
che molto spesso la matematica riesce a
fornire di quello che potrebbe succedere
Nel futuro nel caso si faccia una cosa o
nel caso se ne faccio un'altra possiamo
decidere di fidarci degli esperti Ma la
cosa ideale è riuscire a capire davvero
quello che gli esperti ci dicono e il
linguaggio per capirlo è la matematica
ma alla fine la pandemia è stata un
accidente di questi anni le cose in
realtà sono diverse non è il problema
fisso la pandemia No il problema fisso
di questi anni è il cambiamento
climatico è il riscaldamento globale e
le azioni che dobbiamo intraprendere per
bloccare il riscaldamento globale il
cambiamento climatico sono molto molto
più gravi molto più drastiche di quelle
che abbiamo intrapreso per la pandemia
ed è necessario che tutta la popolazione
abbia una conoscenza matematica che
permetta di accettare le misure ai miei
gravi che devono essere intrapresi
come diceva nilsbor medaglia Premio
Nobel per la fisica nel 1922 e
collaboratore al progetto Manhattan è
difficile fare previsioni soprattutto
sul futuro ma Lasciatemi aggiungere se
c'è un modo per fare queste previsioni e
per guardare nel futuro questo modo è la
matematica ma Lasciatemi ancora dire
qualcosa
pandemia prima hanno parlato di guerre
cambiamento climatico raccontiamo
qualcosa di un po' più divertente e
Allora cambiamo un attimo la scena di
nuovo siamo negli anni 70 c'è un
conduttore televisivo Montil che negli
Stati Uniti conduce una trasmissione a
premi la trasmissione è questa propone
un gioco al concorrente pensate di farlo
anche voi Mettere davanti al concorrente
tre porte LA 1 LA 2 e la 3 dietro una
porta c'è una macchina dietro 32 c'è una
capra voi non sapete quale ma il
conduttore lo sa Scegliete una porta e a
questo punto immaginerete il conduttore
apre la porta Se c'è la macchina l'ha
portata a casa se c'è la capra avete
perso quasi quello che fa il conduttore
a questo punto che sa dove la macchina è
aprire una porta che non avete scelto
mostrarvi che lì dietro c'è una capra e
poi vi fa una domanda voi volete
cambiare la porta che avete scelto e
scegliere l'altra oppure tenete la porta
che avete scelto immaginate di averlo
fatto avete scelto una porta io apro
un'altra cala la capra e vi chiedo
volete tenere la porta che avevate
scelto prima alzate le mani chi vuole
tenere la porta che ha scelto prima
e ora alzi la mano chi vuole cambiare la
porta
bene Molto spesso uno dice Beh chi
lascia la via vecchia per la nuova sa
quello che lascia ma non sa quello che
trova giusto Ma Lasciatemi proporre un
attimo la cosa da un punto diverso il
conduttore anziché aprire prima la porta
con la capra vi chiede volete tenere la
vostra porta o volete prendere tutte le
altre due A questo punto Siccome tuis
mail che One sicuramente tutti cambiate
prendete le due porte ora vi fa vedere
che dietro una delle due nuove porte c'è
una capra ma grazie tante lo sapevate
già c'è al massimo una macchina dietro
una di quelle due porte c'è una capra
Ciò nonostante con la scelta di queste
due porte avete due possibilità su tre
di vincere la macchina cambiare conviene
non è intuitivo Ma la matematica la
probabilità ci permette di vincere
quello che per noi non è intuitivo ci
permette di vedere il futuro e di fare
delle scelte migliori
per finire Lasciatemi rispondere alla
domanda che vi ho Posta all'inizio ma a
me il teorema di Pitagora cosa mi serve
Beh
vi racconto un'altra storia qualche anno
fa mio papà ha Deciso di costruirsi in
sala un mobile che arrivasse fino al
soffitto se l'è costruito sdraiato per
terra e poi lo doveva tirare su cosa ha
fatto si è misurato l'altezza dal
pavimento al soffitto che era 3 metri 36
cm,3 ha deciso quanto Largo voleva il
mobile che era 33,4 cm e si è chiesto
quanto devo fare altro Questo mobile Beh
se l'avesse fatto altro Esattamente come
la distanza tra il soffitto e il
pavimento lo proviamo a tirare su e
errore succede qualcosa di male va a
sbattere contro il soffitto lo devo fare
meno alto ma quanto lo devo fare meno
alto Beh quando tiro sul mobile Ecco che
compare improvvisamente
un triangolo rettangolo compare un
triangolo rettangolo
che ha esattamente l'ipotenusa che la
distanza tra il pavimento e il soffitto
e di cui conosco un cateto Ah e il
teorema di Pitagora e col teorema di
Pitagora mi calcola esattamente
l'altezza del mio mobile che è
incredibilmente più di 3 metri e 34 e
Altissimo questo mobile e la matematica
mi ha permesso di calcolare esattamente
questa cosa ha permesso a mio papà di
costruirsi questo mobile che
effettivamente arriva quasi fino al
soffitto Incredibile la il teorema di
Pitagora la matematica servono a
qualcosa Ma la matematica serve a
tantissimo perché è molto molto astratta
e descrive la realtà Galileo Galilei ci
diceva che il mondo è scritto in termini
matematici in numeri e figure come
triangoli e quadrati e se noi questa
lingua la conosciamo possiamo
interpretare il mondo Ma la matematica
serve tantissimo altre cose di cui non
ho avuto tempo di parlare serve a
decidere dove costruire delle strade
delle linee città metropolitana dove
costruire degli uffici dove costruire
delle case per avere delle città più
vivibili serve a capire come funzionano
le lezioni serve davvero a tantissime
cose la matematica sono gli occhiali che
ci servono per leggere diversamente il
mondo e non so voi ma io senza gli
occhiali Non so dove a sbattere quindi
mettiamoci tutti sul naso gli occhiali
della matematica e andiamo diritti verso
il futuro grazie alla matematica per il
futuro
[Musica]